regardez qui va écrire un livre avec
adil rami l'un d'entre vous qui va
écrire l'hymne avec adil rami
petit indice ça n'est pas jean bie voilà
comme vous savez j'aime beaucoup le tpb
et toute l'équipe et c'est pour cela que
ce livre je les écris avec une personne
qui choisit de relative de tp mp3 et je
suis fier et honoré de vous dire que
cette personne c'est géraldine maillet
dans mon livre je les écris avec
géraldine maillet voilà donc je pense
que je pense que ce tuyau il peut faire
très très mal
c'est un idiot qui peut faire très mal
et qui va faire très malade ce qui était
dit sur moi sont pas les priver le monde
du football
parfois ça plaît parfois s'appelait pas
souvent quand on dit la vérité
ben même pas trop tu vois le premier a
dit kim ap thaler adil rami ouais vous
êtes l'appel bah oui avec plaisir allez
juste après le film regarde tout le
temps l'émission et vous adore c'est ça
c'est la famille c'est vraiment un ami
mais c'est une question dont nous
passera les vacances avec moi cet été
également bien parce que j'ai suivi
géraldine qui a travaillé avec adil rami
pendant des mois et des mois je peux
vous dire que elle a travaillé comme une
dingue dessus et ça va être un élève de
pierre mais quand il servait alors il
est très beau jurer savoir si géraldine
était tombé sous le charme du rami
lorsqu'on faisait tant déçu de ça il va
créer d'attentes attachant parce qu'en
fait il a un parcours complètement
atypique me reymond exactement c'est la
vérité je sais pas si elle va le dire
mais moi j'adore son parcours ce qui
était employé de la ville
ramasser les mécanos il était mécano et
ramasser les feuilles après vous rendez
compte qu'ils se retrouvent champion du
monde sait ça mec nettoyer des ronds
points et se retrouve champion du monde
de football des gens et on va s'appeler
le livre autopsie oui parce qu'il
revient surtout aussi les mauvais
moments de sa vie il ya eu dernièrement
la dernière année a été compliqué pour
lui
entre pamela anderson vandal fait
l'armée parle et où il avait joué cela
mais non il a déjà joué à ça va être un
grand buzz écrit les pins un livre où la
grange
ladrange ce serait chez robert laffont
est déjà fait tradi mods parcours quand
j'étais viré de tf1 j'allais raconter
l'histoire s'appelait télé réalité où
j'expliquais un peu tout ce qui se passe
derrière dans les coulisses un fort
alors vous allez expliquer quoi et j'ai
bien vendu des méfaits content dit moi
qu'est ce que vous a expliqué avait reçu
une belle avance oui mais qu'est ce qui
se passe qu'est ce qui se passait dans
l'équipe mais je racontais comme on
était maltraitée quand parfois on allait
voir certains directeurs de programmes
qui me disait bats toi tant que je suis
directeur des programmes tu n'auras rien
d'autre comme émission ouais ouais tout
ça j'ai tout raconté ouais je l'avais
bouquin j'ai lu le bouquin dans dans les
studios de h2o noyé dans les bureaux
intitulé tout cartonné il ya les photos
à l'intérieur c'est bien ça ouais ouais
on est gâtés ils parlent de vous que
quand il est champion du monde
hamon et vous l'avait appelée pour lui
c'était plus beau jour de la vie de sa
vie passe quand vous regardez tout le
temps à l'étranger avec une parabole
berne et 10 il ya une rigolade parce que
je vous jure que c'est vrai show raconte
ça c'est que j'ai appelé beaucoup de
joueurs de l'équipe de france quand ils
ont été champions du monde
oui jean paul chapu antoine également g4
mais aussi et sans rigoler en fait je
relis chan n'a pas ce que j'ai appelé ma
m'a dit et il était très très heureux
sera quand je la paie oui j'en regarde
en parlent et oui oui merci merci à la
hausse et cyril hanouna tu peux faire
des marques affaire m'a dit qu'il était
tendue il était submergé dans des shows
qui a envoyé à la télé il était
impressionné ou bien il était avec une
meuf nourrir avec sa mère ce genre là à
battre et moi ça mamour également la
daurade et louis beaux soirs mini kessou
adil rami il est grand quand même un
grand garçon ah oui et non mais pourquoi
il écrit pas tout seul c'est pourquoi il
est persuadé que la prétention ah ouais
moi aussi moi aussi je sais les
chroniques chez polycom tout ce qu'il a
besoin de quelqu'un et aussi par
ailleurs c'est compliqué quand on lui
parle de ce nom regardez et bernard
montiel le livre n'a pas écrit tout seul
il ya des prêtres farouk son chien n'est
pas grave
l'écrivain jacques moi non mais c'est
vrai que moi aussi j'ai eu quelques
agents tout cas merci merci d'être là
les shihri à marion quoi qui tient non
j'ai donné l'éditeur chez flammarion et
la retape ne se dit pas ce qu'il me le
dise en 2003 parce que là vous faites
chier tout le monde on va pas se mentir
était chez tout bon ou pas mais pas chez
nous